[Musica]
che costa che cosa vedete in questa
immagine violenza una donna che è stata
appena buttata nel fiume libertà una
persona che si sta divertendo in acqua o
magari arte una cosa è certa le
informazioni che stanno scatenando la
nostra immaginazione in questo momento
sono le stesse
gli stessi pixel per tutti nessuna
conoscenza umana può prescindere
dall'esperienza di sé il celebre
filosofo john locke nel xvii secolo è
fondamentale ricordare che le
informazioni nel senso di dati grezzi
non solo conoscenza che la conoscenza
non è saggezza e che la saggezza non è
previsione ma l'informazione è il primo
passo essenziale per tutti questi
nell'antichità i romani furono tra i
primi a comprendere il valore
dell'informazione controllo delle
informazioni per i romani si traduce in
imperium maius ed infinito controllo
assoluto dell'impero nella storia
contemporanea
l'esito della seconda guerra mondiale è
stata determinato il buon in buona parte
dalla capacità degli alleati
nell'intercettare informazioni che
venivano criptate dai tedeschi grazie
una macchina chiamata up e nick ma la
touring machine di alan turing che tra
l'altro non c'entra niente con
intelligenza artificiale che viene
spesso menzionata come il precursore dei
computer di oggi è nata come conseguenza
della necessità di decriptare enigma nei
giorni d'oggi ogni attività che facciamo
viene tracciata quanti di voi hanno mai
cercato i propri synteam sintomi su
google
pensando di aver contratto malattie
impossibili
nel 2008 a partire un progetto che
google definì come google flu trends che
aveva come obiettivo quello di prevedere
la curva influenzale
il progetto ha chiuso nel 2013 poiché
google non aveva tenuto in
considerazione il fatto che non tutte le
persone che cercano la parola influenza
su google effettivamente sono malate
questo è un esempio di come le
informazioni portano a decisioni e
previsioni sbagliate nel 2014 per farvi
un altro esempio un anno dopo che google
flu trends ha chiuso gli interessi invia
un'email ad alcuni dei propri utenti
congratulandosi delle nozze imminenti ha
inviato anche uno sconto per inviti
nuziali
peccato che la maggior parte degli
utenti erano single
da qui in poi cambierò la mia
presentazione in base alla vostra
preferenza per chi è familiare con black
mirror non c'è ritorno quindi scegliete
bene chi preferisce che continui a
parlare di informazione per favore si
alza in piedi se non siate timidi in
piedi conoscenza
fantastico fantastico grazie mille ora
se pensate che il bug di pinterest fa
semplicemente sorridere
pensate se i governi avessero utilizzato
google flu trends se avessero preso
decisioni che miravano alla salute dei
cittadini sulla base di quella algoritmo
è molto interessante perché entrambi
sono esempi importanti su come
l'utilizzo delle informazioni senza
contesto possa portare a decisioni
disastrose ed è un po oggi quello che ha
fatto la società
basandosi sui dati su informazioni sta
portando il nostro pianeta un punto di
non ritorno
mi piacerebbe farvi vedere un video
estratto da un trailer di un
documentario di netflix che dura poco
più di un minuto che trasmette lo stato
dell'arte della società ad oggi
[Musica]
fa pensare tanto vero siamo in un
momento cruciale per cambiare da qui
parte la rinascita o l'ennesima falsa
partenza
sta a noi decidere ma per avere una
smart society dobbiamo avere smart
humans noi pensiamo che i computer
diventeranno più intelligenti di noi e
conquisteranno il mondo ma il vero
problema è il computer sono stupidi
hanno già conquistato il mondo
immaginate cosa può succedere se andiamo
oltre
se torniamo all'immagine di apertura
arriviamo alla conclusione che le
informazioni da sole non ci permettono
di capire il contesto senza la
conoscenza non possiamo estrarre valore
queste persone hanno cambiato il mondo
ma non avevano alcun superpotere di
sicuro la passione è stata una dei
fattori chiave di successo ma senza la
conoscenza i loro i loro desideri
sarebbero rimasti dei bellissimi sogni
una società basata sulla conoscenza ci
permetterebbe di promuovere e
salvaguardare i diritti umani su larga
scala ho portato un'altra breve video
che vuole portare il messaggio di come
la società della conoscenza possa
risolvere non solo le sfide di oggi ma
anche quelle di domani
[Musica]
no vittime traffico
new fashion week end
stay hungry stay foolish
[Musica]
wow potente vero merita un applauso
la tecnologia è lo strumento che aiuterà
la società raggiungere i suoi obiettivi
solo se alla base delle interazioni c'è
la conoscenza e i valori umani la
conoscenza e il nostro super potere
utilizziamola grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]